>> Laura: JUSTICE DELAYED,
JUSTIFY
JUSTICY
JUSTICE DENIED.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
>> I HAVE ATTORNEY GENERAL THAT
NEVER TOOK CONTROL OF THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT, JEFF
SESSIONS.
IT'S SORT AN INCREDIBLE THING.
>> I'M DISAPPOINTED IN THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL FOR MANY
REASONS.
>> Laura: WELL IT HAPPENS IN
RELATIONSHIPS.
THE PRESIDENT AND JEFF SESSIONS
STARTED OFF STRONG.
THEY WERE TIGHT.
BUT THEN THEY BASICALLY ENDED UP
HEIGHT CLOSURE.
IT'S BEEN THREE WEEKS.
WE HAVEN'T HEARD MUCH ABOUT HIS
FILLING THIS CRITICAL POSITION
OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
>> I HAVE VERY GOOD PEOPLE.
THERE'S NO RUSH.
IT HAS TO GO THROUGH SENATE
PROCESS WHICH TAKES LONG TIME.
WE'LL PICK SOMEBODY THAT'S
GREAT.
>> Laura: WELL, THE FACT THAT WE
STILL HAVE NO A.G. NOMINEE HAS
SENATE JUDICIARY CHAIRMAN CLUCK
GRASS -- CHUCK GRASSILY IN ARMS.
HOW LONG DOES IT TAKE FOR TO YOU
MAKE UP YOUR MINDS FOR WHO YOU
WANT TO BE THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
GRASSILY TAKES A GOOD POINT.
THIS IS NO TIME FOR UNITED
STATES TO BE OUT A ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
WE NEED A PERMANENT TOP LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN PLACE.
NOW, FOR OWN PART, DEMOCRATS AND
THEIR SPONSORS HAVE HAD A FIELD
DAY SINCE THE PRESIDENT
SELECTION OF FORMER SESSIONS
CHIEF OF STAFF MATTHEW WHITAKER.
HE WAS NAMED AS ACTING AG.
LAWSUITS HAVE BEEN FILED BY
SENATE DEMOCRATS TO REMOVE
WHITAKER CLAIMING THE PICK WAS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
>> HE VERY SIMPLY CANNOT INSTALL
A PERSON LIKE MATT WHITAKER WHO
IS HIS LAP DOG WHEN THE OFFICE
REQUIRES QUALIFICATION.
MATT WHITAKER LACKS THE KEY
QUALIFICATION WHICH IS APPROVAL
BY THE SENATE.
>> Laura: STATE OF MARYLAND HAS
FILED AN ABSURD LAWSUIT TO BLOCK
WHITAKER FOR HIS INVOLVEMENT IN
THE EXISTING OBAMACARE LAWSUIT.
>> MY FRIENDS, THIS IS ALL AN
UNNECESSARY DISTRACTION.
TRUMP'S D.O.J. SHOULD BE
DEVOTING ITS MANPOWER AND
RESOURCES TO DEFENDING HIS
POLICIES AGAINST THE RELENTLESS
ATTACKS BY GROUPS SUCH LIKE THE
ACLU.
DOES THE PRESIDENT NEED THE
APPEARANCE OF SEEMING TO BE
WORRIED ABOUT THE PENDING
MUELLER REPORT.
NOTWITHSTANDING BAD BLOOD
BETWEEN THE PRESIDENT AND JEFF
SESSIONS AFTER HIS RECUSAL IN
THAT RUSSIA PROBE.
SESSIONS WAS TOUGH AND HE WAS IN
SYNC WITH TRUMP ON BORDER
ENFORCEMENT.
NOW MORE THAN EVER, WE NEED A
STRONG, SMART, WELL RESPECTED AG
WHO IT LIKED BY THE PRESIDENT TO
DO THE FOLLOWING.
NUMBER ONE, LEAD THE FIGHT
AGAINST NATIONWIDE INJUNCTIONS
ENACTED BY DISTRICT COURT JUDGES
FROM ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION AND
HEALTHCARE.
THESE ARE THWARTING THE RULE OF
LAW, THE WILL OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND THE PRESIDENT.
NUMBER TWO, THE NEW AG NEEDS TO
LAUNCH AN INVESTIGATION OF OPEN
BORDERS GROUPS SUCH PUB
BORDERS GROUPS SUCH -UB
BORDERS GROUPS SUCH --B
BORDERS GROUPS SUCH -- -- PUEBLO
THAT HAVE ORGANIZED THIS AT THE
BORDER.
THESE ORGANIZATIONS ARE CRIMINAL
CONSPIRATORS.
RIGHT NOW, THERE ARE LAWS ON THE
BOOKS THAT A SMART LEADER AT
D.O.J. COULD UTILIZE TO STOP
THIS CARAVAN MADNESS.
WHAT ARE THESE LAWS?
SECTION 274 OF THE IMMIGRATION
ACT, ANY PERSON WHO KNOWINGLY
BRINGS OR JUST ATTEMPTS TO BRING
AN ALIEN INTO THE UNITED STATES
ILLEGALLY, HAS COMMITTED A CRIME
PUNISHABLE BY UP TO 10 YEARS IN
PRISON.
ANYONE WHO ENCOURAGES OR INDUCE
AN ALIEN TO COME CAN BE JAILED
UP TO FIVE YEARS.
SOMEONE WHO AIDS OR ABET PEOPLE
CAN BE JAILED UP TO FIVE YEARS.
IT GETS BETTER, EVEN INVOKES
POSSIBILITY OF THE DEATH PENALTY
FOR THOSE WHO'S ACTIONS RESULT
IN THE DEATH OF ANY PERSON WHILE
VIOLATING THE GOVERNING
IMMIGRATION LAW.
JEFF SESSIONS DROPPED THE BALL
ON THIS ISSUE.
NEW AG MUST NOT.
NUMBER THREE, BEFORE PELOSI
TAKES THE GAVEL AND
INVESTIGATIONS HIT THE TRUMP
WHITE HOUSE, A WHIP SMART,
STRONG EXPERIENCED AG IS NEEDED
TO CORRESPONDENT LEGAL STRATEGY
AND DEFEND THE PRESIDENT'S
POLICIES AND DECISIONS.
THAT MEANS CORRESPONDENT WITH
THE WHITE HOUSE.
THIS REQUIRES HE OR SHE BE
CONFIDENT AND COMPETENT ENOUGH
TO APPEAR ON FAIR MEDIA OUTLETS
TO ADVANCE THE WHITE HOUSE'S
POSITION.
WE NEED TO SEE THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
FORCE, LET'S FACE IT.
WE FLEED A NEW AG TO HELP
RESTORE PUBLIC TRUST AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND THE
FBI.
AFTER THE REPUTATIONAL HARM THAT
COMEY, McCABE, LISA PAGE,
PETER STRZOK AND OTHERS CAUSED,
IT'S TIME FOR THE PRESIDENT TO
TURN THE PAGE AND NOMINATE
SOMEONE WITH EXPERIENCE AND
CREDIBILITY.